Top keyword or keywords. That's one of the mistakes I made you have to do multiple keywords when I was in these other groups
I thought you just went in and let's say it's concrete or concrete contractors
You just type in concrete contractors st
George, Utah, and if it looks good you send it and if it doesn't you don't guys
You're gonna be ranking for different keywords that keyword might be super difficult and the other four or five six
67 are layups, dude. No one's competing
I'll go and take all the traffic for those four rank for those four and that's gonna help and it's gonna bleed over and
It's gonna allow me to rank quicker for the main keyword, right?
If the main keywords concrete likewise are on the flip side you go and do the research and that top keyword is a laydown
Oh, man, there's not even dude all the people in the maps. They don't even have a website shit
It's gonna be easy little do you know if you looked at six keywords the other five they're gonna be a beast, dude
They're gonna be a bitch. It's gonna be really difficult for you to rank
And if you looked at the big picture, you'd realize yeah, you might be able to rank for that keyword
But there's a lot more traffic hiding over here
So it's got to be multiple keywords and in the training we talk about how to build that keyword list
But here's what also school we have 400 plus members in here Theo
If you have a niche you're looking at just ask what key what's the keyword list?
Okay, and I'll probably say have you already built one? Let me see it and I'll then I'll send you mine
Okay, I've got nothing to hide. I'm happy to share